shock and relief
my name is cameron how are you
are you okay
we're gonna take and see mommy and daddy
okay
the moment this four-year-old cleo smith
was rescued after missing for 18 days
well i asked her what her name was one
of the guys jumped in in front of me and
um and picked her up and and i
you know i just wanted to be absolutely
sure that um you know it certainly
looked like cleo
i wanted to be absolutely sure it was
her so i said what's your name and she
didn't answer and i said what's your
name
um
she didn't answer again
so i asked her third time and then she
looked and looked at me and she said my
name's cleo and it was um and that was
it
the four-year-old disappeared on the
16th of october while camping in western
australia she'd been asleep in her
family's tent but when they woke up she
was gone
feared snatched
search teams scoured the area
more than two weeks later though a
breakthrough after an early morning raid
on a house in her hometown
detective sergeant hutchinson
who is the family liaison officer
called
cleo's parents and said we've got
someone here that wants to speak to you
and it was um you know a wonderful
feeling to be able to to make that call
can i say having seen her a couple of
times this morning
she's a little energizer bunny and you
know how she has that much energy i wish
i did i'm about ready to go to sleep
police haven't revealed what
intelligence led to cleo's discovery a
36 year old man is being held over the
suspected abduction i just feel shocked
you know i only feel like just down the
road that they actually found the little
girl
and then i've got little girls here too
and i've got my little niece he's only
four too
the mystery disappearance has gripped
this nation after so many days with no
sign
many had feared the worst
here in australia cleo's rescue has been
described as a miracle but it was based
on intense police work more than a
thousand calls and forensic clues sifted
through more than a hundred people
questioned at the campsite alone
how and why this little girl was taken
is still unclear
but tonight her family is celebrating
being whole again
siobhan robbins sky news australia